great masturbate it rhymes
masturbate is great it's great to
masturbate it's great to masturbate it's
fake to masturbate you got a rate that
masturbate at a high level eight
sometimes you want to get it at ten but
it's fortunately you can't get your
semen to hit it at end but when it
happens again you gotta remember that
moment you own it you own all those
times where you come in in your pants
you go sort of dance you get lost in
this trance of masturbation causing some
what procrastination it's a fascination
time to make relations with this
rock-and-roll station it's uh it started
out making sense that was good that I
loved him shut that [ __ ] cat up
hello guys i'm ryan right i'm jump
although we're gonna check out from the
funny sketch channel CollegeHumor why
wine snobs are faking it this is perfect
for john paulo because john paulo has
started a youtube channel called the
super wine bros you could guess what
it's about based off the title girls are
wireless that sounds perfect yes let's
talk about wine there are so many how
much juice
I never noticed that when it's time to
choose a wine none of us feel like we
know what we're doing this is fancy
I think since we can't taste the wines
before we buy them we're forced to pick
just based on the label this one has a
frog wearing a hat so I bet that tastes
like Mossi this one is by Francis Ford
Coppola I liked his movie so I bet it
tastes like and even when we do taste
them we doubt our own opinions this is
dry this was full body are you sure so
we deferred the opinions of so called
wine actors I can be of some assistance
ladies but the truth is everyone is
pretending because even though wine
connoisseurs want us to believe that
their ratings are objective that one's
fit to drink that is cheap swill and
that is a bottle of ketchup and they
have supernatural powers of wine
discernment in 1934 tastes like it was a
very cold summer that year and the
vendors wife was pregnant with a girl
here's the big secret wine experts can't
tell the difference either I beg to
differ sir my palate is incredibly
refined well fragrant brochet in the you
know
of Bordeaux would say otherwise he
conducted a series of tests on
unsuspecting wine experts but for the
sake of TV let's go there wine pranks 54
wine connoisseurs were asked to compare
a red and a white wine it should be
pretty easy the red is juicy and robust
the white it's bright with notes of
vanilla and oak they're actually the
same wine half of the bottles were just
white wine dyed red and none of the
participants could tell another test
experts were asked to compare two
different bottles one an expensive Grand
Cru and the other a cheap table wine the
ground crew complex very very
interesting I shall be returning to the
ground crew Thunder table it's light
it's flat it's pretty much what you'd
expect well that's interesting because
once again they're good brochet just put
the same wine in two different bottles
and none of the so called wine experts
even noticed white breaks my drink
right all right you convinced me all
wine is terrible and it tastes the same
no why is wonderful of course wines
taste different it's just totally
subjective like all foods we don't need
sandwich experts because we know what we
like peanut butter and sardines what
they're both healthy fats and it's what
I like if you don't like it it doesn't
matter because there's no objective
truth to what tastes best we think of
wine as a high-class item only
accessible by high-class people but it's
just tasty fermented grapes so you know
what forget the snobs take risks and
drink what tastes good to you
wait really you mean I can drink
whatever I want
Wow okay John Paul oh yeah
thoughts thoughts first of all that was
an awesome depiction of reality I mean
that is so true and that was so well put
together so if this guy Adam the one
that is on the screen right now and the
guy that put it together he's awesome
that is so true I mean I've done wine
parties before where like everyone looks
to me like I'm this wine god and only I
can answer any questions they have and
if they try and like pick out a smell or
a flavor like they're like I smell
strawberries and I'm like yeah so I go
great you know they're so happy these
wine snobs if you will which I mean you
know I'm a wine professional by no mean
snob they over dramatis eyes everything
and I think that needs to not be that
way what's the key to being a great wine
connoisseur then what's the key to be in
the wine master just you know drink one
drink wine and when you drink it don't
just take it back take a second to
analyze what's inside your glass you
know you yourself ask yourself what do I
taste in this wine what am i smelling in
this one what what I like about it
that's
you become a connoisseur you figure out
what you like and so you just like they
said in the video and then you start to
drink more of it and what you don't like
and why you don't like it you have to
just learn the words that help you
figure all that stuff out is subjective
that video actually taught me that it is
but I gotta say about college humor
sketches there's always a fact that I
tend to get from it where I'm like you
know what that's true they're out there
kind of making a point right now not all
their sketches but a lot of their
sketches I'm like there's actually a
good point to be made about the funny in
there if you want to know how to you
know go about wine smell real [ __ ] you
know if you're not gonna smell cherries
in the wine if you don't know what
actual cherries smell like so you know
if you want to learn more about wine
when you're at the supermarket walking
down the vegetable aisle start smelling
[ __ ] smell the carrots smell raspberries
smell the limes smell lemons and you
know just build a repertoire of smells
inside of you so that when you drink
wine you're like [ __ ] I smell cherries
you know you know it's funny is I have
this incredible ability to smell
genitals
oh yeah like from any distance a male or
female there's so many different women I
know that they can just come up from
behind me and I could smell their vagina
Wow
same thing with penis and balls I you
know who was it like like okay your
penis and balls yeah you you showered
earlier today mm-hmm
your pubes are in the right amount okay
I your right nut is bigger than your
left yeah he's right penis is average
smaller than it smaller than average
it's smaller than average really small
Wow no that's my penis your penis is
just the right size thanks Ryan
I'm a genital connoisseur that is lovely
maybe later you can show me how you
partake in your genital oh yeah it's
really simple
use make up [ __ ] oh yeah just like the
wine look at that with the wine you're a
general contour and truth is all
genitalia is subjective anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to the Chanel if
you're new to it you can subscribe today
and become a reject like reject all ik
come on alcohol addicted to to this
channel john Paulo has a channel channel
trailers up more videos coming soon
subscribe today so you can get more
alcohol insight like I said before to
every one of my friends if you're an
alcoholic if your dad's an alcoholic
your mom any relative if anyone who
struggles with alcoholism if you want to
amplify your alcoholism because
alcoholism like everyone says is a funny
topic being an alcoholic is so funny
you're gonna scare away so many
potential viewers that I might have
personally I think it's a serious issue
but everyone else thinks it's a really
funny topic there you go now we're
talking now we're taught now we're
talking
but Sara's em search um this guy it was
his birthday on Halloween and he wanted
a shout-out unfortunately I didn't give
him one that I can get across that
comment in time but happy birthday to
you buzzer - um they're not gonna know
who you're talking he's gonna know or
she's gonna know or it is gonna know the
Sara sham is actually a sex position oh
it is it yeah
that's where you get poop in the toilet
yeah take the girl's head you dumped her
in the toilet your head mm kick her down
there she goes unconscious you call the
police you're like my girlfriend is
unconscious I kicked her head while he
was down the toilet eating my [ __ ] then
the cops show up ambulance shows up you
leave in time believe the door unlocks
so they could come in there pump the
poop out of the girlfriends you know
Ches wherever it's like stuck and then
you uh and then you flee the scene II
you never see the girl again where was
there any sex involved in any of that no
it's like the sexual pleasure you get
like a kinky thing it's great yeah glad
that pleasures you don't do that on
anybody ever please we talking about why
do you think Veronica and I aren't
dating anymore
I'm kidding we're still together going
strong and the sex has never been better